hier der direktoren sessel von 1922 23
da hatten die neuinterpretation von 2018
hier der tisch k10 baujahr 1924 und da
die neuauflage baujahr 2008 10 bauhaus
know hows möbelklassiker der bauhaus
bewegung im neuen look
aufgelegt vom deutschen möbelbauer
christian drescher wir wollten
eigentlich die bauhaus originale nicht
auf dem podest heben und museal
betrachten wie sie jetzt museum auch
oftmals stehen sondern gerade das
gegenteil wir wollten sie vom museums
podest wieder ins leben holen das ist
unser ansatz war wir möbel produzieren
und so kam die idee offener damit
umzugehen mit jungen gestaltern
zusammenzuarbeiten und diese bauhaus
möbel in ein neues licht zu rücken
mit dem bauhaus kennt christian drescher
sich aus sein unternehmen bauzeit mehr
als vier jahrzehnten einrichtungs
klassiker aus den 1920 er jahren nach
bisher streng nach den original
entwürfen
[Applaus]
im mittelpunkt immer die gestaltungs
regel der bauhaus schule form folgt der
funktion
jedes möbelstück ist alltagstauglich
aber nicht nur das letzten endes sind
diese möbel etwas mehr als normale
möbelstücke nicht nur profane sessel und
sofas sondern wirklich möbel die die
einen geist transportieren auch so ein
bisschen das ausstrahlen
in den hauseigenen werkstätten von txtr
im kleinen ort lone voerde in
niedersachsen arbeiten handwerker und
designer gemeinsam eine arbeitsweise die
so auch schon am bauhaus von gründer
walter gropius praktiziert wurde walter
gropius grundidee kunst und technik kurz
und handwerk wieder zu vereinen war der
kern des bauhaus geistes unter der
denkschule des bauhauses und ganz
wichtig für die resultate die aus dieser
schule stamm junge gestalter haben für
bauhaus know hows bekannte klassiker neu
interpretiert die berliner designerin
kathrin krailling hat sich den fw 51
vorgenommen den direktoren sessel von
walter gropius tue ich diesen sessel an
dass ich quasi walter gropius noch
gerecht werde
aber gleichzeitig dass man auch erkennt
dass eine neue interpretation von 2900
mit neuen oberflächen und bezügen hat
die designerin insgesamt sechs
verschiedene versionen des sessels
geschaffen dass das bauhaus heute noch
zeitgemäß ist für sie der beweis dass
die designer ihrer zeit voraus warten
das ist irgendwie faszinierend wenn man
irgendwie sich so die kollektion an
guckt vom bauhaus vor 100 jahren was
waren ja alles utopie
das waren ja alles schräge ideen die ja
so an sich nie in der gesellschaft
angekommen sind das was was marcel
breuer walter gropius et cetera damals
gemacht haben nach sah man ja nie in
einem normalen zu hause im jubiläumsjahr
der bauhaus gründung inspirieren die
entwürfe auch andere kreative die
berlinerin jennifer brachmann entwirft
von der designschule inspirierte mode
der deutsch kroatische industriedesigner
konstantin grcic einrichtungs objekte
das label neubauer aus österreich hat
dem architekten walter gropius und dem
maler wassily kandinsky zwei
sonnenbrillen gewidmet möbelbauer
christian drescher glaubt die
designklassiker sind mehr als
wiederkehrende modetrends
die möbel sind natürlich zeitlos und die
dinge die dort entstanden sind und die
architektur aber was für uns noch immer
reizt und was wir bei noch noch als
ansporn sehen ist der der geist dieser
denkschule ob bauhaus oder know hows für
all diese möbel gilt ob baujahr 1919
oder 2019
sie verraten ihr wahres alter erst auf
den zweiten blick
[Musik]